you
everyone is Jerry Aman leeches org and
I'm playing now a 3-2 game how about oh
I don't know let's start with g3 let's
see what kind of a variety will get
starting out a game like this there
let's let's take it into a Kings Indian
attack land alright well they're taking
measures at a very early stage to combat
my light square Bishop considering
Knight c3 be pushed around maybe I'm
okay with that if that structure changes
like this okay well scratch that I'd be
fine with under developing and let's get
this move in if no d 4 i'll go to e2 I
like getting this e for move in with the
knight on c3 so let's see what they they
do about this pressure here all right
let's hunt down their light square
Bishop I got them ready to win upon now
so let's see what they do about that
they're just reinforcing so let's back
up my queen doing this to get my F pawn
contributing they have good harmony
between their palm structure and the
remaining bishop I'd really like to
break down their light squares let's
start off with this I want to be able to
move my up on Queen B 6 pinned my have
fun so f4 let's do it let's be
consistent can't play Bishop e3 just yet
end up in a fork okay that weakens the
square that they've been focusing on
just gave it up like these moves to
reinforce d5 and no they no longer have
upon a d5 and they have a gap on c4 this
is a move but I don't know that I want
to give up this square so easily I'd be
fine if this happens so let's just get
more pieces involved if they play this
I'll get the F file to work with so also
night c4 maybe then I start to I up 'if
I've a bit more because i have this
jumping point on d6 we'll see i like the
flexibility i have all right I don't
want to commit my night just yet let's
just prevent b5 I may do this at some
point yeah actually i think i will night
here bishop d2 maybe the other rook here
mmm g4g five let's try this yeah this
move before here so now I'm threatening
here and then a jump possibly ok they're
going straight in for that something
seems way off with that how about I
actually bypass this pawn and play f5 aw
it takes Knight takes I could play
Bishop f5 but 97 seems to be holding
everything let's go here Wow what's that
move about
well let's make sure g5 doesn't happen
let's open it up here and i have the
bishop hair let's open it up some more
it's thinking about c3 but let's do this
my bishop needs to work this is my X
Factor bishop let's get him playing yeah
let's go here
can't really jump in here Queens boxing
out my night I could maybe look to
soften up this pond with h5 at some
stage could take this night out just
double up or do this one precautionary
move let's just get a quick move in to
keep an eye on that clock hmm let's
double now they could slowly try to
dislodge my night position with be 6 a-6
and then be five so off to come up with
something maybe this is the way forward
g5g for okay that move did not fear me I
didn't figure that because of a five I
have this under control so now they
can't dislodged my night position and
now that the night is moved now I do
this as i get that f5 square for bishop
for a rook so this is this is definitely
good for team white broken down their
light squares pretty sure the computer
is not a fan of that that move because i
do get this break-in and he's having a
tough day the bishop on g7 how could I
really take advantage of this fact that
f5 is basically already a hole under 40
I'm ready to just lure their King out
further so they're going to consider g5
I guess so just Bishop check bishop here
something better
um I'd really like to get a night here
what about this let me a night on this
square I could take twice enough a my
night feels like he's just out of play
in a way on c4 I think this would be a
better square and if he's ever taken i
could take and have a passed pawn and
then maybe operate on the light squares
let's throw this check in just make a
quick move I don't know if I want to go
in here right away mm-hmm I kind of
don't want all major pieces exchanged
it's going to look a little funny but
I'm going to do that maybe queen here I
think this is fine okay
hmm let's hit the Queen first and let's
do this actually this should be fine get
a pass pond put my queen on e for their
night is boxed out okay clean here
really soon hmm let's play over here I
want it guard this square they're going
to grab that pond with check could I
really do this move and get away with it
I could also just lose because of this
stuff man why did I allow this
everything is getting mopped up now no
good now I got to go into a pin Knight
f3 I gotta defend like this well might
be
hold this actually I get that pond now
they should have played Bishop f6 okay
hmm and he's got to stay on that pond
huh kind of boxed out don't know what to
do now they just come over hmm that
works yeah I can't I can't stop they
just pushed through Oh missed
opportunity there just cleaning let me
resign mmm man I had a good position how
could I have better taking advantage of
that they hunted down my deep on for one
which was no good I mean good for them
but yeah clearly I can't just be
dropping my deep on and when it does
drop it hits with check
hmm maybe I should first prevent this
move maintain my queen position yeah
because this exchange now my bishop is
off this square so g5 Queen here night
here I'm just allowing them to move
forward in my position and do so with
tempo g4 throws a punch night g5 throws
a punch and now i'm dropping upon moving
forward again dropping material now and
it's just collapsing it's just a domino
effect from there so i need to stabilize
my position here with something like G
for this pawns going nowhere this night
is under control and yeah just go from
there g4 Queen here and my queen never
gets dislodged this side is under
control hmm ok let's go through it
see the opening happy with obtaining the
bishop hair very early on I don't think
that this is a problem let me just put
it right on Knight c3 is fine with the
z4 idea and they replied pretty quick to
my Knight c3 move but I was going to say
if this I was content with rear out
under developing my night I had in mind
this move is there anything wrong with
that now not really just have this in
mind and now this diagonal is a bit more
opened if they don't have that pond
aunty and I think in the end I know I'm
wasting time under developing but
they're going to have to move this pawn
again I believe at least to kind of play
on the queenside where they now have a
space advantage okay they didn't play d4
I got in EU for choir the bishop hair
and yeah it's just a slow building up
type position right here f4 no issues
here doesn't really like d for now it
does I'm not fine with this yeah I'm
happy to see this i know it under
develops but things are still closed
time is not that big of an issue i have
the time to get the pieces back into
play back into a good square 9c for you
know what does i want to do on this
ephod move this is where i played f5
it's telling me to
hold my ground not commit don't capture
don't push but still maintain the
tension okay this is another option not
show your hand so quick on takes now I
could be taking with the bishop and then
maybe pushing yeah this would be really
strong if I'm able to get here and black
isn't able to reinforce 'if I've with
the piece if I'm taking right now this
is what I was pointing on the game if
I'm doing this they have well I thought
this move which is a move but even this
one I guess as well and the bishop is
there to defend so i could play Queen up
to no fear on this capture because of
this and they want to already give up
the exchange why is that the case
because of night d6 I imagine or
something like this maybe even this is
an idea now since I control f8 crashing
through on f7 plus 4 Wow rook here push
oh yeah that's a problem if the queen is
going somewhere else the night's going
to land on d 696 even a push and the
night can't make use of this square ok
anyhow a short story maintain the
tension is another move i could have
considered here instead of pushing with
f5 they went h6 i want to make sure the
f file was open get my light square
Bishop working now yep a slight pull
here close to a pond and they should
have taken it a slower approach here if
they're if they're really wanting to get
rid of my night the way to go about that
is with first b6 making a dummy move a
six and then finally be five it comes at
a snail's pace but if you want to kick
the night you have to do it in that way
how they played it with a six it allows
the clamping down a five and now he's
cemented in there but what did I really
end up doing with them not allowed did
good to acquire good positions for my
pieces but yeah that's maybe about it
creating a good environment for my
pieces but not executing these
positional advantages as well as I could
so they went with the night retreat I
thought there would be some shift with
that night retreat because of this move
although it's pointing out a capture
another capture and then what ok and
then h5 so just swapping both rooks
first and then playing h5 to be honest
I'm not really a fan of that because I
have my books doubled and I think it'll
take more time for black to contest the
F file you know I'll wait for them to
capture I'll recapture and they're going
to have to come over anyway there isn't
another relevant file to operate on so I
don't think there's anything wrong with
the media day ch.5 there isn't you know
a g5 I probably spent too much time
right around here because there's just
so many interesting possibilities you
put a bishop on f5 and then sneak into
g6 and I now the night control there I
guess with one open file like this the
Brooks will be exchanged
both Brooks will be exchanged most
likely could I have done anything on the
queenside earlier I don't know where I
go for I look to reposition my night
into the d4 square what does it want to
do now let me just look at this a little
bit more this wants to slowly sneak in
here oh you know what I could do I could
look to pinpoint these guys something
like this this pawn fixes these two I
could have considered this as a plan and
Bishop to see eight yeah okay didn't
didn't consider that in the game I like
to reposition the night let's have two
and a half 97 mmm that's going to be a
trouble big trouble for black hitting
the rook hitting see 597 suppose they
take take back and I guess at the very
least I could grab that pond pac-man
mode hmm I didn't see this 97 move it's
too focused on this square through in a
check this was almost like a passing
move v3 hmm it's calling for 97 again
still holding an advantage plus 2 it's
still once 97 I just didn't see it
should have seven queen here you know
not to upset with how I play it up to
here and this is where I went astray
wants to push and it can't be taken
because of Queen here but this should be
fine as well no yeah this is just a
rock-solid approach basically kills the
bishop there's no hope for him to
activate
on any of these three squares or even
this one so he's pretty much a dead
bishop you know he can never really see
any dark squares on my side of the board
if he's not getting through any of these
squares any of these four squares he's
he's a dead piece hmm yeah should have
played g4 i went with before looking to
open up the other wing and now it's
tricky still had something right around
here after night there ah i think i was
i was considering this move but yeah i
had this fear of them targeting my
bishop but i have Knight takes pawn and
then i could even think about a night
check here Knight takes Queen I take
their queen yeah I had to really be
accurate here and I clearly wasn't it's
still only a slight pull for black with
this variation and not anymore hmm yeah
tough to know what the correct square is
for your king at this point and now it's
just beat is it not it's only holding it
as even oh I have a perpetual
thought as much as they did that's why
they thought as much as they did in the
game I'm seeing it now when i played
this move i thought why don't you just
play this right away they thought I
don't know for how long it was I guess
you could check it out with the time
here the move times how much time was
spent they spent 10 seconds on Knight to
f3 and in that time I was just wondering
why is this not played sooner it's
because I could just get away with the
perpetual check and I need to do that
because from here it's lost trying to
defend here this was my last chance to
save a draw perpetual check check well
is it really clean here no you have to
give a check here and if the king is
coming over here check there hmm to be
pretty accurate here with the Queen I'd
say this one isn't too bad but yeah I
really had to go in for that Queen here
crawling up into a ball defending it's
not really working out I think they
could have actually hung on to that pawn
maybe think how they played it was fine
now they improved their King position
really well and this pawn push I can't
take cuz I'll drop my night and I'm just
struggling to find a move I can't move
forward the fish was boxing out my night
not just in big trouble here can't win
okay well
sure what to say on this one I liked how
I I like the positional how I played it
positionally but didn't convert didn't
execute well when I had these good
squares for my pieces and my opponent
did well to come back there at the end
start throwing punches at me and yep
dislodge my my strong post here with my
queen and it just crumbles from here
dominoes ouch okay well as usual feel
free to leave any feedback to this video
in the comments section below and I hope
you got something out of it that's all
for now take care bye
you